the habitat of the clownfish is
unfamiliar territory for this group of
Indian Forest Service officials
they've gone underwater off the Andaman
Islands to explore this rare ecosystem
some are diving for the first time one
of them is Shashi Kumar he came from
Gujarat 3,000 kilometers away to take
part in an exercise conducted by the
international climate protection
initiative Shashi Kumar anoying
colleagues want to learn how to live in
an ecosystem without destroying it the
biodiversity of the Andamans makes that
easy you can see coastal beaches
mangroves and forests little forest
which you can't find in any where
officers like them will have to protect
1,400 kilometers of coast Siva Kumar
Kapoor saw me from the wildlife
Institute of India says local residents
must be involved the fishermen
communities are living that they go 40
years there being a fishing and all
those things suddenly we cannot tell
them that you shouldn't go fishing them
that's just the problem 3,000 kilometers
away in Gujarat the Bharucha district is
one of three which are Shashi Kumar s
responsibility 500 people live in this
fishing village industrial pollution and
the requirements to use nets with a
larger mesh make their lives difficult
it's hard to convince fishermen like
Shosh by to use resources more sparingly
earlier we used to catch 15 kilos of
fish a day now it's only 5 or 2 kilos
sometimes we don't catch anything at all
the officers know these people rely on
what the land and sea provide for them
in a twenty square kilometre area next
to a disused port they've planted
mangrove trees the villagers used to
just cut down the trees and use the wood
but after lots of discussions Shashi
Kumar has convinced them to rethink
their attitudes step by step now they
want the ecosystem services of mangroves
they want fishes from this area they
want this area is a controlling erosion
so they get a very a very good
agriculture in the future the villagers
will be able to plant more mangroves and
keep an eye on them to benefit even more
from an intact ecosystem
you